thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for your patience and Welcome
to our press conference I know you're
waiting for the publication of the
conclusions which are coming shortly
I've been told first may I invite the
president of the council
news foreign
foreign
foreign
determinate
yes thank you so much indeed we had a
very good European Council we do now
have a very good and solid roadmap to
keep on working on the topic of energy
prices
the leaders have given the Strategic
guidance we wanted on the proposal that
we have put on the table on Tuesday and
that will be discussed next week Tuesday
in by the energy ministers let me focus
on a few topics that we have discussed
intensively the first one is the topic
of the joint purchasing of cars here
leaders supported very much the idea to
allow companies for the joint purchase
to build consortia
and to work together and to join forces
so to increase our Common Market power
for the demand of gas there's one
binding element in it that is when we at
the beginning aggregate the demand 15
percent are binding to be aggregated as
Demand on the market together as a joint
aggregated demand
the second topic was the focus on how to
limit episodes of excessive gas prices
and this is the discussion Around The
Benchmark for gas prices the so-called
ttf
we know that the ttf reflects mainly
pipeline gas but as we see that the
market is Shifting and more and more LNG
gas is coming to the market the ttf does
not reflect the true market situation
anymore therefore we will develop a
complementary new index to reflect
better the LNG price situation and for
the meantime
we are going to establish a market
correction mechanism exactly to limit
episodes of excessive gas prices and to
make sure that there is a clear order in
uh the build of the market
so here we will work with the energy
ministers to submit a legal proposal to
operationalize this Market correction
mechanism
of course leaders also discussed a
second topic which is a potential
mechanism to limit the influence of high
gas prices on the cost of electricity
we had a Frank discussion which further
clarified on one hand the opportunities
and on the other hand highlighted the
challenges
we will analyze the financial impact of
those countries with a lot of gas in
their electricity production what does
it mean if we cap the gas to reduce the
inference of gas on the electricity
price
and the second topic which has to be
analyzed is the flow of of subsidized
electricities to non-eu neighbors here
too we will work with the member states
and with the council formation to find a
well-balanced and common approach on
these issues
the commission will also come back to
the issue of state aid next week the
college will adopt the proposal on the
prolongation and the adaptation of the
temporary crisis framework
this will give member states an improved
ability to support their companies in
the face of the current crisis while
preserving a Level Playing Field so
common rules for everybody
for example thanks to the extension of
time limits for State support or new
options to support companies reducing
the electricity mud this new revised
state aid crisis framework will be then
decided on next week in the college
moving forward to the topic of funding I
just mentioned the state at
opportunities but there's also a strong
look at the opportunity at the
possibilities to support vulnerable
households and vulnerable businesses we
are aiming to make available up to
around 40 billion euros of funds that
are still still available from the
previous mff
so with that member states will be able
to help the most affected by the energy
crisis by be it the vulnerable
households or smes but indeed more is
needed to support small and medium
companies but also larger industry to
deal with the high energy prices and
here the topic of investment is very
important the investment can be financed
through the European level that is the
vehicle re-power EU that is right now in
the process of being decided in
Parliament it has already been decided
in Council so we're moving forward to
the try log hoping that this instrument
then will be finalized as soon as
possible
and here is the possibility for all
member states to have common European
funding to invest in their companies in
their smes to help them to make the
transition away from fossil fuels into
for example Renewables cheaper sources
of energy and thus prepare for the
future
we have had a very good Council on all
these topics and I think I will stop
here and I'll be happy to take questions
thank you madam president we'll take a
few questions indeed Irene you were
first
please
so I would like to ask you why did it
say take so long to have an agreement
um could you blame some member states
for being more selfish than others
despite the fact that we Face such as a
crisis thank you
no we are we are all extremely serious
and this is a an extremely serious topic
and also a difficult topic a complex
topic it was very important to make sure
that you are all very very clear about
what we are deciding because what we
have decided is the the very strong
framework and it will play a fundamental
role in order to to reach the goal that
we have determined and you know because
we we knew that it would be a difficult
European tour in fact the fact that we
were able to have an agreement only in a
few hours in is at the contrary in my
opinion a very strong signal of a United
approach and determination to work
together in a European way in fact the
surprise is the fact that we are able in
a very short period of time in a few
hours to get an agreement on such a
difficult topic
I also
um have witnessed that we had intensive
but very constructive discussions and
there was this strong will you could
feel it in the European Council to come
to a common conclusion and of course
different member states have different
priorities but if you look at the steps
we've made forward now this road map
that now has to be worked on and then
implemented it is a joint purchase big
step forward it is the rules for sharing
gas so the solidarity agreements and the
rules that have to be followed in case
of a severe disruption it is the topic
of excessive price prices and how to
limit them and there are two different
models are on the table now to be worked
on the one is on the ttf level
so the overall gas
gas trading level the ttf and the other
is looking at gas that produces
electricity and that's that determines
the price of electricity and then we had
on top the big topic of investment in
European small and medium Enterprises
and in European industry all over Europe
to prepare them for the future so to
help them to bridge this difficult time
of high energy prices to be able to move
forward and to modernize so a big agenda
and for that I must say it was a
relatively short time
Francesca basso Correa
today results
when will European citizens be able to
see the effect of today agreements
because we waited a lot
thank you
I'm confident that very soon the effects
will be we will be will be seen because
I think that we sent also a clear signal
to the markets it means that we are
ready to act together that we are able
to act together and it's there is a
strong political way that's why I'm
confident that there will be a fairly
soon and of course we need to work very
hard and urgently in order to implement
as much as possible the different
measures that are on the table
so um
European citizens will over time
seeing the effects of our efforts
ongoing
let me allow to have a Look Backwards
with you
at the beginning of this horrible War
if we look at the eight months that have
passed since then
Russia has cut two-thirds of all its gas
supplies to Europe two-thirds that's
more than 100 billion cubic meter of gas
that Russia has cut
we have been able to compensate this
completely by having other suppliers
like for example the United States and
Norway by saving a lot
by making sure that we have skimmed the
windfall profits of the energy producing
companies and support the vulnerable
households and vulnerable companies so
you can already see over the last months
how much work has been done to
compensate such a huge amount of gas
cuts and if you look at the price curve
curve at the end of at the end of August
it was around 350 Euros per megawatt
hour
and we see since then with all the
interventions we have started and all
the work we've done on the prices that
we are down now to a level um that is
between 120 and 140 still too high it
has still to go lower but by that I want
to show that you have an ongoing effect
that citizens can see from our work
foreign
extravagant
[Music]
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
the College of Commissioners has decided
on the proposals put forward by the
commission on Tuesday and if I call we
call it correctly on Tuesday in the
press conference I've been asked what
are my expectations to the European
Council and I told the one who asked me
that that my expectation is to get
strategic guidance on this big package
this big proposal by the commission and
that's exactly what we have managed and
got today that was the goal because all
of us know that these very highly
technical energy questions have to be
tackled with the energy ministers and I
think on Tuesday will be the next
extraordinary energy Minister meeting so
um what the time sequence is concerned
as soon as possible are we going to work
to deliver on this roadmap
um with the joint procurement if I got
your question right uh what is The
Binding element again perhaps in the
joint procurement
um yes The Binding element is so the the
majority is incentive for companies to
work together uh voluntary of course to
work together and to do that by building
for example a Consortium which is a big
economic Advantage for the companies
because you increase massively your
Market power and there is a smaller
amount that is binding in the demand
aggregation what does that mean it means
for 15
of the storage companies should tender
or put forward publicly their demand
together that's the binding element then
offers will come and of course every
company is free to choose whether they
take the offer or not so that is the way
the joint procurement is organized but
it's of course a big incentive if you
are able to to build con a Consortium
and on your third part
um households and businesses
indeed there are several
options for member states that we
offer to support because we all know
that there is different fiscal space in
the member states and if we want to have
a Level Playing Field if we want to have
the same opportunity in our single
Market we have to offer to all member
states options to support their
households but also to support their
companies there is first of all the
so-called windfall profits so the
excessive profits of energy producing
companies can be skimmed and invested to
support
households many member states are doing
that are choosing that we have enabled
that a few weeks ago the second point is
that 40 billion of unspent funds from
the last mff
are still available we flexibilize them
so member states can take this money and
invest it into supporting households and
businesses
and the third element is the work on
repower EU
as I said I hope before the end of the
year it will be agreed between Council
and Parliament and repower EU is
investment in infrastructure
cross-border projects Renewables Energy
Efficiency and can be up to 300 billion
euros it depends a bit on what the
choice of member states is but here you
see
besides the state aid three different
options for the different situation
member states have to invest not only in
households but also in companies
thank you madam president Mr President
tomorrow we convene again at 10 A.M and
we'll have another press conference in
the afternoon please have a good night